comex et nous mais mac c'est bien le
cours des dernières années vous êtes en
quelque sorte devenu à porte parole pour
les premières nations que ce taureau qui
vous plaît reculez l'eau parfois ce rôle
une grande responsabilité loge sa dette
honnêtement ça dépend des fois parce que
il ya des jours où ça vient tellement de
toucher personnellement si je rencontre
un jeune de dix ans 12 ans qui s'appelle
sam yonne parce que ses parents ont
choisi la pluie comme ça à cause qui
sont venues des concerts des choses
comme ça quand je rencontre des jeunes
dans les écoles ces soirs là quand je me
couche j'ai un peu de misère à dormir
parce que j'arrive pas à réaliser
l'impact n'a pu avoir dans la vie de
certaines personnes bien je vais à
l'écrit chaque semaine
parti de loin parce qu'à une certaine
époque métier délinquants accro aux
drogues
hélas aujourd'hui vous faites des films
l'amusé la télé est partout alors
comment on réussit à passer d'un extrême
à l'autre pour faire les bons choix faut
faire les bons choix il faut faut
s'écouter un jour ou l'autre on a une
opportunité qui arrive fait equal déclic
pour vous wapikoni mobile 2040 2015
quand j'ai rencontré manon barbeau quand
l'équipe du wapikoni venu à mon village
qu'on parle de délinquance et de
consommation s'était installé des années
de ma vie où c'était peut-être la fin
pour moi de cette ville en fête et web
commis a été ma naissance artistique où
j'ai pris conscience que je pouvais
faire quelque chose de bien dans ma vie
vous êtes en train de me dire que ces
genres de programmes qui font une énorme
différence en tout cas pour vous ça
fonctionne et ça sauve beaucoup de vies
ça sauve et énormément de vie des gens
des communautés autochtones ça fait
quinze ans maintenant que ça existe
j'ai vu cet homme étendu sur le trottoir
sachant que rire c'est l'arbre se cache
une histoire je pars li mu et que vous
avez un quatrième album après cinq ans
d'absence et il ya une des chansons à
succès sur l'itinéraire en hommage à
votre père qui vous abandonner lorsque
vous étiez de tous jeunes et que vous
avez revu plus vieux parce que vous vous
souvenez de la fois où l'avait revu et
je joue aux francofolies de montréal
énorme foule on jouait dehors et
peut-être quinze mille personnes et
était en plein milieu et non seulement
j'ai demandé à regarder les gens dans
les yeux en spectacle mais cette fois le
fallait c'est pourquoi j'ai regardé en
plein milieu de la foule ccu lui et je
me rappelle juste en plein milieu du
spectacle gillett a alterné le concert
parce que j'ai su qu'ils étaient cinéma
je l'aï vu dans son élan et c'est à
quelques mois plus tard que j'ai revu le
même regard donc oui je le reconnais
tout de suite parce que mais moi je me
rappelle je me rappelle exactement ce
qui est arrivé parce que j'ai vu la
déception dans ses vieux de voir que son
fils que je le vois dans cette école
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais en même temps non du fait bien les
choses puis rien qui table pour rien
cette journée ça nous a peut-être
rapprocher en fête ou mieux encore de
nous éloigner parce que l'alcool la
drogue ces choses là ça nous a éloigné
pendant trente ans donc ça nous a permis
de passer un moment à travers ses yeux
j'ai vu j'ai vu énormément de choses je
peux le temps d'arrêter j'ai pris le
temps d'appuyer sur pause aussi dans ma
carrière de tout lâcher par un jeu de
dame des neiges mais je vais m'occuper
de lui je prends du temps avec lui et ça
a été ça a été aujourd'hui je dis que ça
a été un privilège a été très dur sur le
moment parce que toutes sortes
d'émotions qui devient en tête de ce
directeur pourquoi moi je dois m'occuper
de lui alors que lui était jamais là en
fait mais c'est ici mais aujourd'hui
j'ai compris que sa mort était une
naissance pour moi oui les itinérants
était malade mais mêmes à travers le
silence à travers nos regards à travers
ce qu'on leur dit vivre à la maison et
mais j'ai appris à pardonner
j'ai appris à accepter sa maladie
[Musique]
j'ai pu lui dire avant que par ça ça a
été une bénédiction ma vie et mon père
avec pedro parce qu'il est prié toute sa
vie pour je me fasse baptisé et le jour
de mes 30 ans pour mon anniversaire j'ai
choisi de rebaptiser et alliés tels à ma
grand-mère était leurs marmots fils et
ça a été son dernier dimanche hauteur et
est parti après s'il ya ou pas ça y est
j'ai vu ce que le wagon sur terre et il
partit donc d'avoir écrit cette chanson
là c'est trop long la chanson que
c'était plus mal à écrire depuis des
quatre albums que j'ai fait mais mais en
même temps ça m'a permis de tourner la
page ça m'a permis d'avancer
peut-être même des temps meilleurs pas
aussi sans ian quel plaisir merci
beaucoup de plaisir merci je te fais
prend le soleil je change de saison en
parfaite aliments je suis en parts et
rotation n'essaie plus me dominer est
invité pour mon humain